hearts at his first formal Royal
Engagement with his family Prince Louis
I think he's going to be a chip off the
old block and be just like Harry I think
it'll be a bit of a rebel he sort of he
pushing the envelope sort of thing so I
think he's gonna be one to watch in the
future the five-year-old stole the show
at the big help out a day where people
are encouraged to volunteer in their
Community for Louis that meant helping
his mom Kate Middleton with planting
another one
Royal also got to ride an excavator with
his dad Prince William
Louis also tried his hand at archery
but we think Louie's favorite part had
to be roasting marshmallows for s'mores
with siblings Prince George and Princess
Charlotte
a long time and their parenting skills
are really good as well you know they're
not afraid to shut signs of in public
and Kate will often you know kneel down
and sort of talk to the kids and show
you know displays of affection with the
children which we never saw previously
the volunteer event followed King
Charles's coronation where all eyes were
on Louis who got to attend the ceremony
at Westminster Abbey the five-year-old
scored a spot next to his big sis
Charlotte I think for princess Charlotte
we really see her taking after her
mother Kate you know she's so composed
so put together she's sort of mastered
that sort of Royal approach to public
appearances at a really young age but
she's also become Prince Louie's almost
sort of caretaker at some of these
events as well she's the one that keeps
him in line following the ceremony Louis
joined the royal family on the balcony
of Buckingham Palace where he had this
cheeky moment
a lot of people were talking about
Louie's two-handed waves on the on the
balcony what'd you make of that I think
we're going to see lots of like years to
come and I guess I think the kind of
parents that William and Kate are
they're not going to stifle that too
much you know I think they're probably
going to let him let him be his own
person to a degree but I think you'll
certainly want to watch as the years
develop yeah and we'd like some more
sweet moments with Louie just like these
oh my goodness
you've made his day
I'm going to be part of him now
[Music]
thank you